hello there
my name is david tubberis
i live in lagos nigeria
i'm the director of technology and
products at parallel school
people often ask me
after working so many years as a
technology if i still could well of
course i do
and i think simpler lens
course
helped me to go back to the basics all
right not just that i'm not earning
three times more than what i used
in my previous job at bunker clinton
i was the head of engineering
my work was
a supervisory one
especially
working out
at my job position for several years i
realized i was in touch
with my programming skills my
programming work was reduced to fifteen
percent of my work
i wanted to queue together to constantly
so i wasn't for promotion and also i
wanted to do more programming i also
didn't want to start a fresh of course
so i took the full stack java
development course at september
prior to simple learn
i was pretty much a self-taught
java developer but the cost was very
good i have not only learned java
but i've also learned
other technologies i've been exposed to
imaging technologies such as dawkins
test engine selenium
jenkins and the likes
my course ended sometime around february
2022 and around the same time i got a
job as director of
technology and product at parallel
school with two times my salary at my
current job i design
implement
architectures using
great programming practices
performing code reviews
ensuring exceptional code quality
delivery is also fundamental
in fact now
i do freelance auditing
additionally my overall earning has
increase threefold
i'm becoming better
and better
and it's because i'm always learning